[Music]
we have it checking words we have it
well first we have it limiting the input
to five letter
words and those are uh five letter words
that actually are in the list
so that's good and then we have it
checking the correctness of each letter
which is also good
um although there is one thing that
isn't quite right um
let's see the target word is oh yeah so
like let's uh
let's see what's a five letter words
with two
two letters that are used that are in
the target word so we that
if we have this word saves that's that's
my guess
um
so these are all in the right position
the last three letters because their
target word is gives
but it's also saying that s there's an s
here that's in the wrong position
um
and in actual the actual wordle game
it would not say that this
s is in the wrong position because that
was already sort of used up that in the
target that s in the target word is used
up by this one that was in the correct
position
i think what we need to do is we need to
take two passes
comparing the target where to end the
guess
and
the first pass will just look for the
exact matches where they're in the right
place and this will sort of use up those
letters
in the target word so if the target is
gives
we take one pass we find these three
match
and then
[Music]
the only the only remaining letters
are g and i and then we take another
pass and we'll check you know
we'll check
whether uh
these letters in the guess
are in those remaining letters
g and i
uh so yes at the lar if the guess these
remaining guess letters s and a are uh
in the remaining target letters
okay so let's do that
all right so first we'll take one pass
over the word
over the words and just look for the
correct
or the result or the where the we just
look for places where there are
exact matches in the correct position
all right and if they're not
or sorry if it is in the correct
position then we should
mark that that letter is sort of used up
okay so there's two ways we could do
that we could we could mark the letters
that in the target word is being used up
or
um
we can actually just keep track of the
remaining letters so that are not used
up so let's let's do it that way i think
in this case it'll be a little bit
simpler
so uh so there's the target letters
there's the guess there's also remaining
let's call these remaining letters and
uh
director of length zero
okay so
so
if it's correct great
else
um
remaining
and uh well we can grow the vector this
way remaining
and we'll just that target letter will
add it to the remaining
the sort of the list of remaining
letters okay so that's our first pass
over the word
and then we'll take another a second
pass over the word
and uh i guess
let's do
the same thing actually this looks a
little bit
better like that
iterating over the letters in the guess
even though it's effectively the same it
sort of
feels more correct that way
all right so um
so
if
you can actually reuse this code here so
if the guess is
not or if it's not already a correct
result
so we can say
okay if
the guest
does not match the target
letter here
and
the guess is in the set of not target
letters but remaining letters
then
then we'll say the result is in the word
okay
and let me think about this we also need
to in this case we actually need to
remove that remaining letter
uh
from rem we need to remove that letter
from the set of remaining letters so
let's uh we can try this here so if we
say
let's
run this function okay compare
words
uh
target is gives and we're making a guess
saves
that totally did not work this logic is
messed up here
oh you know what we can do actually
let's let's start the um
the results
instead of an empty character vector
let's start it with a character vector
where
the starting value is like it's just not
in the word and then if we find matches
or if we find yeah if we find correct
letters or inward letters then we'll
replace that entry
so let's say we'll do
rep
not in
word
five okay so that will
that creates a character vector with
at length five with all uh the same
value not in word
and that'll be
um
that'll be our starting
value for result and then we'll replace
those entries as we iterate so let's try
this again um
compare words
okay word gives and saves
okay that's right so previously the
problem with saves it was the first
asset said was in the word and now
now it's saying it's not in the word
because that's used by that the last s
there
but
there could be a problem let's see
yeah all right this is not an actual
word so this would not be accepted by
the whole app but
um
but we can test this out by comparing
like we want
one of these g's to indicate oh actually
that's
that's actually not helpful so sorry um
this is a total nonsense set of
characters but what we're trying to
figure out here is
um
we know that this s will sort of
be marked as correct and it'll consume
it'll use up uh the s and the target
words so that this first s will not be
marked as inward
but will the same thing happen for the g
um when it's just in the word like one
of them should be marked as
in the word but in the wrong place but
not not both of them
um but what's happening is that they're
both being marked as inward so we
actually need to uh if we have this
match here
we need to remove that guess letter
from set of remaining letters
i always get i always have to try this
out so let's say
match
match function
what does this do
match it returns okay this is okay good
got a little lucky here so the match
function always sort of i always have to
test it out and uh i think this is the
right this is the right order of
arguments
um
so i'm saying like
hey given this letter and this vector
with a bunch of letters um
what's what is the first position where
this letter shows up in the second
in this the first thing shows up in the
second thing i think that's right let me
make sure
the vector positions of the first term
in the second um
i think that's right let me just
so if i if these are all g
actually yeah one
okay great
all right so i can say um
remaining
and give it this index here so i say
match
where uh
yes
okay so this is a way to remove things
from a vector so i can say um and
actually why don't we why don't we just
try this out this is a
good good way to test things out in r so
if i say
say remaining
i'll just i'll just actually
create some variables locally and we'll
we'll test them out in the console
remaining letters are
g
and i
and
let's say guess
is just
g
so it's a little bit different here
because from what we have here because
here we're using
guest bracket i but let's just take this
code
and remove that so
so here we're gonna try to remove g
from the remaining
uh remaining vector
oops
that did not work
oh you know what
sorry there's a much easier way to do
this
so um
oh yeah there's a much easier way to do
this okay
so this would have worked if it was a
list but it doesn't work for character
vectors or for like atomic vectors
what we can say is remaining is
uh
let's just take all the letters that are
not equal to that guess
all right um
okay so
you know let's
let's try this again let's with some
just example code here so remaining
is g i
yes is g oops and
you can actually just print this out
with this without assigning it
so
oh yeah sorry gotta get rid of that i
so false and true
so um
yes it does match this one so that's
false and it does not match this one so
that's true so we say remaining
our guess is not equal for meaning and
that gives us just i
and that is what we want
oh no that's actually not true
because we only want to remove one at a
time right so
let's see
but this will remove all of the g's if
there's one
um if the guess has one so let me okay i
gotta think about this again
[Laughter]
no no okay here it is here it is so x
minus three
is there okay all right all right all
right character
let's see so we're gonna we're gonna go
back to the match thing so let's say
remaining
let's see how did we do that what did we
do before um
right the index was okay
we did let me just do this we'll do
match guess
comma remaining okay
so
let me just
just
g and g just we want to make sure that
we just get one
of them that's position two that's the
first match there so great so what then
we want to say is remaining
bracket
minus
okay so that removed
that one entry that's what we want
all right so let's do
minus match
yes
okay
all right let's try
the
pair
words let's see we can say
that we did that one
that looks correct uh and then we also
did if we put a couple g's in there we
just want the first one to say that it's
in the word
and that's right
okay
um
all right so now we've fixed up our word
comparison algorithm by taking two
passes
and let's uh
let's try it out
okay so again we still know the target
word is gives
and when we said i'll
that looks
right and if we say
saves
great it's not marking this s as being
in the word because we already used it
up
all right excellent
okay now uh
now we need to give it we need to have
it keep track like
accumulate all the previous results and
keep printing that out
so um
let's see let's just make sure if we
type in gives
great they're all right
okay cool so um let's see i think the
way that we can that we should do this
is we can actually just store the
results
um the previous results in a
uh
in a vector
or sorry in a list so let's say
let's create a list called all guesses
and we don't have to do anything uh
fancy with reactivity here
there may be cases where that's useful
but right now
we don't need it if we find that we need
it then we can we can make that change
but let's say all guesses is a list
and every time that somebody makes a
guess that
makes it past here
then um
we will add that to the all guesses list
let's see we could store the whole all
that information yeah let's do that
um
yeah so let's say all guesses
and
input dollar guess
okay and this is going to be a string so
actually this is uh this is just gonna
be a character vector for right now
yeah that's that's fine
and then
what we want to do is
um okay well
this is not the most efficient way but
that's how we're going to do it
so
we can do a
so sorry right now this is going to
store all the guesses but it's not going
to do anything with them it's still just
going to print out the most recent one
but we also we wanted to
update this text box
with all of the previous results
or all the previous guesses
so there's a number of ways we can do
that um you know again i'm just going to
try to keep things simple
so
let's
we're going to append this most recent
guess
to all all guesses and then
let's just
iterate over each of them and
um
and do the check uh every
sorry we'll check each word
and that's gonna happen every time
somebody enters in a new guest so again
this is not super efficient but it's
it's fine for what we're doing right now
so
this time i'm going to use uh i'm going
to use v apply
so this is like applying a function
over
many items so the items are all guesses
function that takes in
that particular guess and does something
with it so um
oh and then let me just say
you have to specify the return type for
reapply
so
format the result and then this will
this will return a character a vector uh
so each each guest will get this this
treatment where it you know returns a
string that looks like this
and then we're going to get that vector
back and then we should do something
with it so but let's just say um
oh string
that and then
let's see if that works so um let's
guess i'll again
and saves
oh that's replacing it that's not what
we want
oh you know what
it is double double arrow here because i
was using a single arrow it was just
scoping this
assignment within this uh this render
text block here so it wasn't actually
modifying this copy of all guesses it
was just modifying a local copy of it
so i need to use a double arrow to make
sure that i'm modifying this
um
this copy of all guesses out here let's
try it again
i'll
saves
okay well that's sort of right it's just
sort of sticking them next to each other
and remember this is a character vector
and what we want to do with it is
well actually why don't we let's take a
look at it this is this can be handy a
handy tip here so you can stick in a
browser statement here
which will take it to the it'll go into
the r
debugging console every time it hits
that line of code so let's reload the
app let's say again let's do the same
guesses i'll
go
okay now it hasn't
put it printed anything out here but we
are in a console
uh in our console that's stopped right
here so we can say what is this out
string thing
okay it's actually it's this uh it's a
character vector looks like it's a named
vector which doesn't matter for our
purposes
um and that's the that's the content
okay great
that looks like that now if we do make
another guess saves
say out string
and
uh it's a character vector with two
items in it and we actually want that to
them to be printed one on top of each
other so let's just let's say um
paste out string
collapse
equals
backslash n
so that's what we want
there's a backslash and a new line right
there
if we want to see what it would look
like we can use cat
on that string
so that's that's what we want to come
out here all right
so
let's do uh
let's take this and put it in
here save that i'm going to quit this
debugging console you can do it by
clicking stop
or capital q
and we'll delete that browser statement
there and so we don't keep doing that
and let's run the app all right
aisle
saves
oops gives
pretty good at this
[Music]